body camera footage shows the disturbing
moment when a chicago police officer
fires a shot that would paralyze a
13-year-old boy it happened on may 18 on
the city's west side officials say the
13 year old jumped out of a stolen
vehicle and began to run off later he
appears to turn around with his hands up
that's when he's shot at the time the
boy was unarmed no weapons were found at
the scene the family of the boys say he
was paralyzed as a result and may never
walk again they've since filed a federal
lawsuit against the city of chicago
arguing the shooting was not justified
right now the officer involved in the
shooting is on leave the civilian
officer of police accountability is
investigating the case stay with the law
and crime network for the latest
developments in the story